bonsoir bonsoir ovidie alors voilà vous
êtes une pornstar mais vous préférez
qu'on vous appelle travailleuses du sexe
et c'est encore plus beau en anglais
parce qu'on dit sex worker alors là
évidemment ça le fait disons que c'est
vrai que c'est ce que j'ai écrit dans
l'introduction mon livre j'ai demandé à
g crise j'étais une travailleuse du sexe
mais c'était surtout par réaction à tous
les médias qui m'avait appelé l'intello
du porno et vous avez un dock de philo à
18 ans quand même hein pas étonnant
qu'on vous appelle l'intello du porno
mais gens qui ont des dogues en ad il y
en a des milliers en france et le fait
de commencer mon introduction pas je
suis une travailleuse du sexe était pour
remettre les choses à leur place je suis
actrice et réalisatrice de films pornos
voilà alors vous publiez un livre vous
savez comment on fait du duduk
il fait tout ça s'appelle c'est chez
flammarion est la bonne
voilà alors envie dit c'est un essai
politique qui défend la pornographie
d'abord épique et ensuite exposé les
thèses du féminisme pro sexe parce que
vous dites il n'y a pas de liberté
totale s'il n'y a pas de liberté
sexuelle vous êtes un petit peu contre
les féministes classique je dirais
isabelle alonso c'est pas votre votre
tasse de thé on peut dire quoi
vous opposer aux féministes classique
pour qui le sexe est souvent une
aliénation alors que pour vous c'est une
libération voilà comment on peut résumer
les choses et pour certaines militantes
gelé appris en lisant vos écrits pour
certaines militantes féministes
classique la levrette par exemple c'est
une position interdite parce que c'est
une position de soumission la critique
que je fais virer du féminisme moderne
c'est surtout que le féminisme a proposé
aux femmes de devenir des libres
consommatrice et des libres aux
travailleuses et pas vraiment des femmes
libres en tant que féministe procès que
ces infamies ski qui a une critique
sociale beaucoup plus large que le
féminisme moderne qui a juste proposé
que la femme soit l'égal de l'homme sauf
que si on part du principe que l'homme
est aussi soumis
deux c'est devenu swayze à autre chose
qu'à l'homme aujourd'hui mais elle est
toujours soumise militer pour une
pornographie de libération d'une
certaine façon oui en quelque sorte oui
et c'est vrai que les quelques femmes
que j'ai repris j'ai repris dans mon lit
parce qu'en fait le but du livre s'était
aussi montré que ça fait plus de vingt
ans qu'il ya des femmes qui sont
féministes et qui sont pornographe ça
c'est quelque chose que j'en oublie
beaucoup ont dit tout le temps la
pornographie c'est fait par les hommes
pour les hommes non non non non ça fait
20 ans qu'il ya des femmes qui font des
films pornographiques sont féministes
pro sexe et c'est vrai que c'est ces
femmes là que j'avais envie de mettre en
avant dans ce cas
vous êtes opposé la pilule comme rio
alors c'est vrai cet étonnant quand on
vit votre bouquin c'est à dire que vous
êtes contre la pilule je pense que si
j'avais eu l'âge de ma maman j'aurais
défendu et la pilule c'est bien évident
par contre tout ce que je dis c'est
aujourd'hui sachant que les moeurs ont
évolué on peut peut-être penser à
quelque chose qui va au delà sous c'est
vrai que je fais une certaine critique
de la pilule moi même je ne prends pas
la pilule pourtant je suis je suis marié
je suis pas jamais été enceinte d'une
sexualité régulière est alors
toujours moyen de java justement mais
ovidie je veux dire la daf et tout votre
travail de libération des femmes des
millions de femmes qui refusent de
prendre la pilule parce qu'elle pense
que c'est pas sain de mettre ce petit
truc chimiques excusez moi mais c'est un
truc ces petits trucs chimiques dans mon
coeur richard n'est jamais tombée
enceinte c'est bien la preuve que ça
marche
donc je sais pas tout nous des recettes
je vais pas dire aux femmes arrêtées
pour la pilule je viens juste attention
c'est vrai qu'on a distribué comme des
smarties à plein de gamine dont moi moi
j'ai pensé à prendre la pilule quand
j'étais adolescente à partir de 14 15
ans et c'est vrai que c'est ce que je
raconte dans mon livre m'est arrivé des
tas de problèmes à cause de ça y est je
suis tombé sur des médecins qui étaient
des fervents défenseurs médecine moderne
qui disait mais non c'est pas possible
de tomber enceinte sous pilule etc etc
et c'est vrai que je me suis retrouvé
dans les situations incroyables à
saigner j'ai même auto avorté parce que
je ne savais pas que j'étais enceinte et
j'ai perdu j'ai perdu mon bébé sans même
savoir j'étais enceinte alors j'étais
une gamine est mon médecin me dit mais
non c'est pas possible vous étiez pas
enceinte et sert à la pilule c'est
génial donc mon propos c'est plutôt de
dire faites attention la puce est pas
quelque chose de complètement anodin il
faut faire attention c'est sûr c'est
mieux de prendre ça plutôt que tomber
enceinte on va me dire et l'état de
gamines sont et planning familial qui
sont en simples jusqu'aux oreilles alors
qu'elles soient pas voulu c'est sûr il
vaut mieux ça mais quand on se sent
capable d'avoir des sexualités
alternative de pouvoir oui avoir de
sécurité sans portée des petites graines
mais je trouve que c'est plutôt pas mal
il ya donc d'autres solutions laurent
incroyable incroyable et seulement
quelques lignes dans la vie non mais
attendez ce n'est commencé dans la
littérature des fois comme sur trois
lignes et puis ça change le monde ouais
comme pour la coque
elles sont venues ces pilules 2
je vais changer de marque ce qui vous
offusquez aussi ovidie c'est le côté je
dirais qu serré du cinéma pornographique
1 ça c'est drôle ça bravo qui
vous dit finalement que dans les films
pornos à part la fellation et le
cunnilingus la pénétration vaginale et
anale ou ou la double pénale vaginale il
n'y a pas tellement finalement mais y'a
pas grand chose d'autre quoi
sérieusement il ya des très grands films
qui sont produits dans le monde où il ya
au moins pour moi un grand chef-d'oeuvre
pornographiques tous les mois et c'est
vrai que ça présente des sexualités
autre que tout en
exhorant voilà sado maso steve jobs
voilà urophiles vie c'est ludique et
puis le fist fucking j'ai bien connu le
fist fucking
d'ailleurs contrairement à son père
lorsque vous dites c'est que les les
pratiques qui sont considérés
aujourd'hui comme marginal dans le
cinéma porno sont déconseillés aux
acteurs de x pour leur standing c'est à
dire que finalement une fille qui veut
être star si elle fait du fist fucking
n'y arrivera pas mais c'est pas un point
encore il faut attendre non mais lorsque
je trouvais ça hypocrite c'est que on
peut faire des pratiques très très rare
de jouer dans la pornographie
conventionnelles et à côté de ça il ya
des pratiques comme je sais pas la
bisexualité masculine m'ont dit oh mon
dieu c'est sale alors qu'une fille qui
s'est pendu pénétration pendant un quart
d'heure ça choque personne moi il ya des
pères il ya des pratiques que je trouve
vraiment hard et qui sont pourtant
concert comme conventionnelle et que
j'ai jamais fait en 45 film il va vous
refusez la nage
c'est marrant d'ailleurs pour fuser
l'anal sauf avec des femmes et des
objets mais quoi par exemple gendt et
les couleurs entre que je vous rends pas
compte je ne connais pas
quoi comme objet ce qui est une liste
précise donc je ne ressens plus je
devais de mariage je ne rends pas compte
non mais sérieusement est-ce que c'est
pas vous qui tape le cul serré là
c'est d'un côté vous prenez comme ça
l'europhile ilfis le king et là je
prends pas ça attention attention
attention le fisc oui ça c'est autre
chose pas mal de sexologues américaine
enfin le conseil à leurs patientes parce
que ça permet trouvé son point g est de
montrer comment aux femmes comment elles
peuvent et jacques hull et donc je
trouve que c'est assez intéressant d'un
point de vue féministe parce que
parce que c'est vrai que ce n'est pas ça
j'ai pas que tu avais un [ __ ] massol
pas parfait c'est vrai que trop peu de
femmes ça fait sont capables d'éjaculer
je trouve ça vraiment intéressant que
des femmes féministes effet défendre il
est en train de révolutionner la france
risque de rebond tu crois que j'en fais
trop
vraiment besoin bruel jamais blasé
si c'est trop moi je freine je comprends
vos experts qui est tout simplement
bien alors reprenons reprenons alors
nous on était
donc on ne mettait pas la récusation
circulation des
vrais
vieux remparts et que ses fans iront
prendre tout ça non mais elle va
regarder l'émission et j'aime pas les
maths alcool ce soir est excité
au manifesto c
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus